I'm a young warehouse manager that takes ownership for anything and everything
that goes wrong.
This seems to offend by coworkers.
How can I fix it?
Um,
okay.
Classic Dichotomy.
Leadership question right there.
You've gone too far.
That's what's happened.
So what you have to be do,
what you have to do is don't be offensive.
When you take ownership,
when you take ownership,
you can't be offensive.
When you take ownership.
Some people get offended by that.
So when you say,
Hey,
you know what?
This is mine,
I got this.
That bothers some people
when you say,
you know what,
this is my fault.
I'm going to fix it.
That even that offend some people.
What the tone?
Just the tone of like,
no,
this is my fault.
I got this.
And you do that three dot three times,
four times,
five times and all of a sudden because,
oh,
what?
Everything's his fault now as he's got to fix everything they,
he doesn't think I can fix it.
You can offend people with,
with,
with all kinds of stuff.
You don't have to work very hard to offend people.
I mean there's people get offended when you say something nice to them,
you know what I mean?
You know what I mean?
I was watching,
uh,
I met,
I met the University of the yoga dude that does like yoga videos.
He's got red hair.
His name's spears.
Yeah.
I met him just randomly getting off a plane.
But he's,
he what?
I,
I've spears or Sears?
Sears,
I think it's Sears.
Maybe speak what I say spears.
I don't know.
I know the guy though.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Very funny guy.
Very cool guy.
And I was,
once I met him,
I was laughing.
I was checking out a couple of videos,
but one of them was,
you know how to be offended at all things and it's,
it's,
it's hilarious because that's exactly what people do.
People,
some people can get offended by anything.
Yeah.
So that's what you've got to watch out for it.
Even when you're taking ownership,
people can actually be offended by that if you go too far.
So instead of overtly stepping up and taking ownership in this particular case,
then you can tell what's going on here.
My brother here,
young warehouse manager,
he's fired up.
He wants to make things happen.
He wants to get after it and so what does he do?
He's like,
Oh,
I read extreme ownership.
I'm going to take ownership of everything.
And that's a great attitude to have except for you can offend people when you go
too far,
cause you've got to read the second book that I got into leadership so that you
can,
you can balance that out a little bit.
So instead of saying like,
Hey,
this is mine,
I'm going to take ownership of this and make it happen.
Instead you look at someone,
you say,
Hey,
you know what?
Do you want me to take care of this?
Oh Hey,
you know what?
That's probably in my department.
You want me to take care of that?
So that way or like,
hey,
it seems like this should be something I should take care of.
You want me to handle that instead of me,
me,
me.
I got asked a question the other day at a Q and a in the court.
The question started off with the person started the question with,
I've got the moat,
what was it?
I've got the question that everyone in here needs answered.
So,
so,
so out of the gate I was like,
okay,
so we have a situation here,
right?
Because that immediately tells you that in that person's head they've got,
they've got the question that everyone needs answering.
So there's already an ego scenario happening like out of the gate.
So same thing here.
You don't know if you're going to touch someone's Egos,
right?
So when you say,
look,
this is my ideal and I'm going to fix it.
Like some people will take offense to that.
So again,
you soften those a little bit.
Try and give credit up the chain of command,
right?
Try and give it credit down the chain of command.
Instead of all take ownership.
It's like,
hey,
we got,
what if you say we win when credit gets doled out,
get past that credit on,
pass it to your peers passage,
your subordinates,
pass it to your boss.
So that's it.
Take ownership.
What you need to do at this point,
young man,
is take ownership of being offensive you.
And when you do that,
you're going to be less offensive.
If you're going to be milk more covert.
Hey,
guess what?
Remember I said earlier,
like you don't get to pick the boss.
You,
you don't get to pick your boss,
you,
but you get to pick the relationship you have with them.
You don't get to pick your,
your peers.
You don't get to pick your subordinates.
You get your team,
hey,
can you pick them?
Yes,
you can quit your job.
Can you hire the right people?
Yes you can,
but look what you got is what you've got.
You've got to work with it.
You don't everyone up,
man.
I wish everyone was more fired up.
Like I am.
Like,
that's not gonna go.
Well,
you know it does.
It's great that you wish that,
yeah,
that's not going to go well.
What you have to do is you gotta you gotta you gotta.
Here's another one.
This is similar,
right?
Millennials.
Well,
Hey,
one of the things that,
what are the things,
this is a very simple,
you know,
I've done,
I've done the millennium questions a thousand times and you know,
the Vietnam veterans,
the Vietnam draft,
these compared to them like,
hey,
we can talk about that again.
We don't need to.
But if you've got a,
if you're in charge of millennials and you think to yourself,
millennials thinks everything's,
they think everything centers around them.
What do you do as a leader?
You know what I do as leader?
I make everything centered around them and they perform and then they get after
it.
And as they grow up,
they learn that everything doesn't send around them.
But I bring them there.
Why?
Because I formed a relationship.
Because I listened to him.
Why?
Because I understand them.
Hm.
So you don't get the team that you want.
You don't get the boss that you want.
What you do is you play the game up and down the chain of command and form
relationships up and down the chain of command that you want.
What relationships do you want from up the chain of command?
You want them to listen to you.
You want them to give you what you need.
Do you want them to get out of way and let you do the mission?
What about down the chain of command?
You want them to support what's happening.
You want them to get after their job.
You want them to step up and lead.
That's what you want.
If you have an antagonistic relationship because your millennials think
everything's about them,
well then guess what?
You're not going to be able to have any influence on them.
Any real influence.
You can have the imposed will on them,
but the imposed will is a is a paper tiger,
right?
It's not real.
It only lasts when you're there and guess what they're doing.
They're looking for another job.
So take ownership of being offensive and be less offensive and more covert and
can,
you know what bro?
Young warehouse manager keep getting after it and it will pay off and the fact
that you're fired up and you're crushing it,
crushing it with a little bit more tact and you're going to one day you're going
to be making it happen.
Yeah.
We got time for one more question.
To add though,
a little tip,
I think that,
I think you taught this too actually.
I realized this one I embraced extreme ownership.
You can't say,
Hey,
I'm going to take extreme ownership of this.
Like it's,
it's one of those things,
it's like just like taking the high ground,
right?
You get in like a thing with somebody.
You can't say,
I'm going to try to take the high ground and then it doesn't work like that.
Like it really just gave up the high ground when you announced that you were
taking the higher ground,
gave it up.
Exactly right.
Same thing with extreme ownership like in this situation.
So if you're a very good point thing is I get it man,
when you're like,
you know,
I'm taking,
and he even said,
I take ownership of anything and everything that goes wrong.
Anything like straight up,
he's your guy.
Right?
Solely it might indicate,
I'm not saying he's doing this,
but he could be going,
hey guys,
no worries.
I'm taking extreme ownership of this situation.
You know,
like if you say that kind of stuff.
Yeah,
I could see that would rub some.
What's odd,
and this is a very good thing to understand about human nature.
Everyone's jealous of you.
Everyone's jealous of each other.
Everyone's jealous of everyone else.
No one wants you to win.
Right.
It's just like,
so when this guy is stepping up and the crowd starts to pick at them,
they start to pick at them and they want to pick them.
They want to pull them apart.
Yeah.
That's generally what the crowd wants to do to you.
When you step up,
when you elevate yourself,
generally the crowd wants to pick it you and pull you back down.
Does he think he is?
Yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
So if you're aware of that,
then you can combat it by when instead of elevating yourself in an overt manner
where everyone can see you saying,
I'm going to take ownership this right now and get it solved.
No,
you sit back and say,
hey,
you know what?
This is probably my fault.
Do you want me to let me,
let me try and take some time to get it fixed?
Everyone goes there actually kind of happy.
They're like,
yeah,
it was your fault.
They kind of,
they're kind of like,
it's okay with them,
whereas opposed to I'm going to take ownership and there's this dichotomy.
Leadership.
You read extreme ownership.
Awesome.
You gotta read dichotomy too.